How I Met Your Mother star Josh Radnor
anchor the CBS have come for 9 seasons
as the unlucky in love Ted Mosby working
his way into viewers hearts with his
adorable smiles constant optimism and
pretentious pronunciation skills oh you
think it should be pronounced
encyclopedia a common mistake
but if you look at that squish together
AE symbol in this here encyclopedia
you'll learn that it's a ligature
derived from the anglo-saxon rune
however since the hit show ended in 2013
Radner has been noticeably missing from
the limelight since so many people loved
his character on the series everyone
wants to know why he hasn't been in any
other high-profile projects so let's
explore why Hollywood won't cast Josh
Radnor anymore am i a at the movies
Brandner didn't have very many credits
to his name before getting cast as a
lead and How I Met Your Mother
aside from a small appearance in Not
Another Teen Movie he'd only had guest
appearances on various TV shows How I
Met Your Mother launched him to stardom
and his most notable role since then has
been in the TV sphere as dr. Jed Foster
on PBS's Mercy Street in other words
Radner just hasn't shown that he can
anchor a film yet which could make
Studios wary of casting him and risking
poor box office returns ted mosby
eternal it's often tough for actors who
spent a long time playing one part to
shed that identity to many viewers Sarah
Michelle Gellar will always be fluffy
Daniel Radcliffe will always be Harry
Potter and Josh Radnor will always be
Ted Mosby this can make it difficult for
actors to move on from career defining
characters and can make it hard for
casting directors to see them in
potential roles just ask Mark Hamill
looking for love like Ted Mosby Radner
has also been trying his best to find
miss Wright in real life if you're
looking for the word that means caring
about someone beyond all rationality and
wanting them to have everything they
want no matter how much you destroyed
you it's love he hasn't married or made
mysterious mother children with anyone
yet but there have been plenty of rumors
surrounding his partner's Radner split
with actress Lindsay Price whom he met
on the set of How I Met Your Mother
after a year of dating into
thousand nine he was linked to Twilight
actress Julia Jones in 2013 and later
dated actress Marisa Tomei in 2014 after
that reports say that he's dating Friday
Night Lights Beauty Minka Kelly if we
learned anything from Ted it's that
finding that special someone can involve
a lot of trial and error tapping it out
the actor is also working on other
writing projects that may keep him from
screen work including securing appeal
for his as yet untitled book on his
attempts to close answer the big
questions about spirituality the book is
expected to follow close an ongoing
quest that takes Ratner from his youth
in heartland Ohio to the unexpected
lessons of celebrity and Beyond and
closely tied up behind the lens
Ratner won the Sundance Film Festival
dramatic audience Award for his 2010
directorial debut happy thank you more
please which he also wrote and starred
in since then
Ratner has also written directed and
starred in the film liberal arts and is
set to direct but not star in the
upcoming sci-fi drama the lead rather
said he got into writing with happy
thank you more please in order to close
give himself a great film role adding
that by writing directing and acting in
his film he can create projects that
feel personal dabbling in music Radnor
is part of the band Radner and Lee along
with Australian musician Ben Lee and in
October 2016
Ratner announced that they were working
on a debut album so I understand you're
writing songs for your album that's
great
yeah and you play instrument I do not
live or he's little when I'm writing an
album yeah we don't you don't want we're
instrument free as well oh yeah we have
a support group called Ross songs for
God and women Radner said the album will
feature mellow folk songs co-written and
performed by the duo decided to write
one song together and we had so much fun
that we wrote eleven oh and then we said
let's make an album so we're cutting a
record taking the stage while he's been
missed on the big and small screens
Ratner has been a regular feature on
popular stages for the past few years
for example in 2015 he appeared in the
fewest surprise winning play with grapes
and most recently he could be seen in
the battle online at the Lincoln Center
Theatre opposite Elisabeth research a
turnaround Radner has made some eclectic
choices since the ending of How I Met
Your Mother and while he may not be
following the stereotypical path of most
actors he's still been keeping himself
busy with valuable and original projects
like his festival friendly drama the
seeker Radner smarts and ambition should
serve him well in any field here's
hoping we just get to see a little bit
more of him soon thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to